大家好 我是来自深圳国家金融科医测评中心的罗峰
很高兴在数据要素可信流通技术目科的第八奖中
跟大家做一个隐息算产品
安全内分析要求的标准解读及分享
本次分享主要从标准编制背景 编制思路
标准内容 以及标准应用实践 四个方向进行讲解
去年1月份 我们看到国家数据局等部门
发布了数据要素乘30行动计划
2024至2026年
文中在强调要深化数据空间
影子计算 缺化链等技术的应用
促进数据合规的高效流通及使用
那么影子计算对于数据流通的价值在哪里呢
我们认为影子计算不仅仅是数据要素流通的旧设施之一
通过密码学 可信应件等技术
实现了数据要素的安全可控 流通及融合
同时 影子计算还是推动各方
尤其是数据持有方进行数据要素流通的一个重要引擎
因其在技术层面上将其数据持有权和使用权进行了拆分
保障了数据持有者在数据流通过程中的基本权益
相较于一般的软件产品的设计考量
可能更多是有限考虑产品的一个功能实现
是否符合用户的需求及习惯
那么再其次再考虑软件的一个整体的坚弱性和可高性
储备事业强奸管或者强安全需求的行业
否则产品的安全考量相对较弱
主要是通过一些漏洒或者常见的一些加固措施
去保障产品整体的安全性
而影子计算产品的我们认为天然就有高安全的一个基本需求
不管应用于什么行业
那么安全始终是起最基本最核心的一个诉求
其次才是性能上的提升以及功能上的实现
我们认为从宏观的视角上来看
影子计算产业的发展
其本质就是一个不断提高安全水位
不断面临安全可振挑战的一个过程
也是一个从可信再到普及应用的一个过程
只有过去各方保护监管机构的一个信任
确信使用相关产品不会造成属于泄漏的前提下
才有可能实现大规模深层次的属于要素流通
所以我们看到影子计算的一个标准体系在前期建设中
那么主要围绕也是最先开展的研究内容
也是影子计算的安全性的相关的一个要求
但是影子计算技术路线是多样的
安全特性也不一
各技术路线在实现方式
性能安全成本开销应用长性的方面
都有比较明显的差异性和优缺点
难以一概要论
所以前期的安全标准体系建设中
基本都是针对某一技术路线
例如多方安全 铃帮学习 可行指引环境
在特定的技术路线的应用场景下
然后进行一个标准的编制
提出一些具体的安全要求
对标准比较了解的同学可能知道
标准需要具有一定的适应性
对安全标准来说
我们安全要求一上来就定得太高
那么要求影子计算产品具备安全可证
其实不太现实的
也起到任何推动作用
定得太低 但也不行
所以标准的编制要符合当时标准编制的
实际的技术应用发展形化
以及实际的应用的需求
但随着技术的不断眼镜
产品应用及市场需求的不断力发展
我们发现其实部分的投谱企业
在产品的安全性上
其实已经高于此前的一些标准的一些要求了
但基于统一的安全的词兵基准
所构建的标准
已经很难去区分标准
就是产品和产品之间的安全差异性
那么导致注重安全产品的厂商
反而体现不出来产品安全性上的一些优势
那么最终导致整个影子计算产业
难以良性循环和发展
这个时候继续一套安全分级标准
让各机构及自身能力
向更高的安全要求去对齐
从而促进整个影子计算产业的安全水位的提升
那么如何去构建一个安全分级标准
这里有两种方式
一种相对比较简单和直接
就是在原有的各技术路线下的标准体系
体系组织上去构建安全分级标准
例如构建通话安全计算 安全分级标准
联盟学习安全分级标准
那么这种标准的构建方式
相对来说编制难度和公度量
相对来说较低
因为只要在原有的标准安全要求之上
那么结合实际的一个技术的一个发展和需求
那么提出一些安全增强要求即可
但是缺点是缺乏统一的安全性度量标准
使得标准和标准之间
对于同一安全级别的定义
可能会存在明显差异
最终使得标准应用的情况下
应用的场景当中
那么不同技术路线产品之间
也无法进行很像的一个安全性比较
第二种方式是尝试构建统一的安全性度量标准
那么再通过统一的标准去构建通用的
是用于不同技术路线的安全分级标准
却拉通所有也许算产品的安全性水位
这种中间方式的好处
在于不受限于特定的这些路线
但难度和挑战也会大得多
经过研讨的我们最终还是决定采用第二种方式
作为标准的一个研制路径
经过长期的标准研制和修订
在2024年2月份的时候
由深圳国家军会设部中心联合蚂蚁充量动舰
等8家业内的头部机构
联合发布了隐私算产品安全能力分级要求标准
该标准也是首个拉通
并适用于不同隐私算技术路线的
同样安全分级标准
结合不同应用场景
对安全等级进行了五级的划分
并提出具体要求
该标准也是为产品的开发方和使用方
在产品的设计
产品的选型的过程当中
提供了相关的指引
那构建统一的安全分级标准
首先要考虑的是
如何给予安全分级维度
解安全分级界线
设计出统一的安全分级框架
安全分级框架的设计是否合理
会直接影响整个标准的指向及应用
在安全分级界线设计方面
需要从我考虑多个因素
比如说在就是层面上
要考虑安全安全跨度的合理性
每级的安全跨度差异性不应太大
那么从定义层面上
要考虑边界描述的行情性
需要定义的边界
教维清晰且亦理解
从最后的标准的应用层面上来考虑
要具备场景的适宜性
不同的安全等级
需要能够满足不同的应用场景的差异化的安全需求
但是具体的后面
什么应用场景
需要达到什么样的安全水位
这个主要受限于
主要受到应用场景中参与方的可信度
共享数据的价值
以所属行业的安全特性
各个因素的影响
在安全分级维度方面
我们不再以具体的技术路线的
安全时间特性
作为品牌安全程度的一个考验方式
从整个安全性的
更为底散本质的角度去释放
从公积视角看
其实就是品牌它的工具成本和收益
那么从防疫视角来看
就是看它整个产品的工具体育能力
以及它风险的管控能力
在工具成本方面
我们进行了非参与方攻击和参与方攻击
位置攻击和椅子攻击两个维度花分
我们可以看到
为参与方的攻击成本
却要远高于非参与方
虽然二一参与方能够实施
更多的内部的攻击路径
攻击方式和攻击效果
可能会更好
但首先
该攻击方式
是需要取得其他机构的一个信任
及授权的
尤其是在多个机构的联合参与的情况下
可能这个成本会更高
而非参与方的算
只能实施一些外部的攻击
可能攻击的手段方式极为有限
但是前期的攻击成本要少得多
而椅子攻击和位置攻击相比
以及攻击
其实只基于已有的攻击方式
而位置攻击的实施或实施的攻击
其实是一个以示答案
进行复限的一个过程
而位置攻击
其实就更像林队的落洞挖掘
或者非队的落洞挖掘
是一种探索未公开的一个攻击路径
因为前期的探索成本会比较高
所以相对的它的攻击成本要远高于
椅子攻击
椅子攻击其实也存在明显的攻击成本上的差异
比如攻击人员的水平的要求
然后攻击设备的要求
还有其他包括攻击条件的要求
为此我们进一步将椅子攻击
划分为了一般水平攻击以及高水平攻击
一般水平攻击实施一般的程序开发运为人员
或者硬件的设计人员
通过一些常见的攻击攻击
然后能够实施的一些攻击
包括一些伪造一些软件
或者基于硬件上的一些差异和硬件数据的读取
等实施的一些较低成本的一些攻击
而高水平攻击是指需要专业的一些理论的基础
以及一些专业的攻击设备
以及其他一些一般水平攻击无法实现的攻击类型
例如一些技术专家通过复杂的数学方式
实施的一些算法类的攻击
包括这种软硬件的一些篡法攻击
以及一些化机构的合谋的攻击等等
那么在攻击的收益方面看
那么我们分为了非约定型一些路和约定型一些路
非约定型一些路是指
行业内没有约定的可泄露的一些信息
是指数据石油者
对数据石油者会造成较大的这个利损失的信息
例如这些原始数据的泄漏
或者基于一些中间泄漏的一些信息
能够推导出一些有价值的信息的信息
都属于非约定信息
那么对于攻击者来说是收益最大的
也是实施各类攻击的最终的一个目的
那么该类信息的泄漏
因为我们认为是不可接受的
但某些特定的中间结果的泄漏
基于该中间信息其实难以进行
因为数据会一些有价值信息的推导
那么这些信息我们认为是对数据石油者
会造成太大的实质性的权益损害的
我们认为是可接受的一个信息泄漏的一个影响
至于什么样的中间数据
多少中间数据会直接或间接
推导出多少原始信息或者有价值的信息
这其实需要一套严谨的方法论
进行可量化的验证
也是整个标准在后续落地过程当中
相对比较难的一个部分
那么通过结合攻击成本以及攻击收益
进行分析其实可以很清楚的判断
哪些是严重风险
那么比如说非参与方的一般水平攻击
它直接导致了肥脸信息
包括这种原数据或者有价值的中间信息泄漏
这种风险我们认为就是一些严重风险
是首先需要满足的一些或者保护的一个方面
参与方的一些位置攻击
去获取一些约定信息的泄漏或者非约定信息的泄漏
那么由于一些成本我们已经非常高了
所以这一块我们认为是一些低风险的方面
然后适用于一些更高安全的拥有场景
去制定相关的一些安全要求